The Joe Rogan Experience I can remember
being in um
once uh Def Jam happened and we started
having a lot of success putting out
music and I'm still probably at NYU
um
labels would come around and want to be
involved in one way or another and and
one label asks like what do you
attribute the success of this to after
all it's not music now these are people
in the music business who are wooing us
wanting to work with us and they're
telling us they don't hear it as music
that doesn't even make sense today right
no no no now it's it's the world has
changed the world has changed wow but it
was a completely alien underground form
of music and because people were rapping
instead of singing that was one piece
that didn't
wasn't understandable and then because
the music was like
it's yours where it's it's a drum
machine there's no Melody there's no
it's it was too foreign at that point in
time for people to understand it as
songs
wow it's hard to it's it's shocking it's
ridiculous and and in in some ways like
there's a song I produced with um
Run DMC and Aerosmith Walk This Way yeah
and the whole purpose of doing that was
to demonstrate
this is music this is music and this is
not only is it music
it's familiar music you're just not
you're not seeing it like you're you're
somehow
removed from what's happening but it's
easy to see if you so again if you
create a demonstration so that's what
Walk This Way was was I looked for a
song that was
familiar
and that the Way It Was Written in the
original version the Aerosmith version
the phrasing of it was essentially a rap
record the verses are
it's not melodic it's all about the
phrasing that's how rap works
and the beat you know the introops that
was already a known break beat in the
hip-hop world they they had never heard
in hip-hop club no one had heard of
Aerosmith no one had heard of
um walk this way but they knew the Toys
in the Attic break which was just that
beat not the song
wow yeah let's listen to that can we
play the intro the intro to Aerosmith's
Walk This Way I remember when you did
that I remember that being a very
polarizing song absolutely because
people didn't know what to think it's
like some people thought you were
ruining Walk This Way by adding Run DMC
and some people like why do you have Run
DMC with rock and roll it doesn't make
any sense
[Music]
that piece is the Toys in the Attic
break because it says Toys in the Attic
on the record
just that
so that would that was and so if you
went to a hip-hop club you might hear
that
wow but I grew up on Aerosmith and I
grew up on AC DC and I grew up on Ted
Nugent you know I grew up on rock and
roll music
and um
when I saw this
disconnect
this was the way to like bridge the gap
just to just to explain what was
happening wow how was it received in the
music business when you did that
um
I guess the first thing was radio like
it I remember uh I guess it was wbcn in
Boston yeah played it once Mark parento
I can't remember if it was Mark parento
or who else was there um Charles
Lockwood era no tell me another name
God that's all I remember like DJs the
morning mattress was Charles Lockwood
dare and afternoons was Mark parento
yeah I don't think I don't know that it
was either of them but it might have
been again I I don't remember I just
remember that bcn played the song and it
was a big deal also because it was a
rock station playing a hip-hop record
yeah and I remember that there was this
outrage from the audience you know take
that garbage off
and then Within
a few days it was the most requested saw
on the station wow yeah so it was like
it definitely divided the audience yeah
but the best things do that's that's
what's really exciting when you when you
hear something new and you don't have a
reference for it your first reaction
might be to push it away
you know I remember the first time I
heard the Ramones when I was in probably
junior high school and I heard the
Ramones and that was the first really
punk rock fast music I ever heard there
were I don't think there was any before
the Ramones
so if you're used to hearing normal
Tempo rock and roll and then you hear
the Ramones
I just laughed it seemed like a joke you
know it just seemed ridiculous and then
eventually it became my favorite thing
how did Aerosmith react did you come to
Aerosmith and try to bring it to them
did the label guy I just had the idea of
doing the song and recording the song
with with Run DMC and then the label
said why don't we reach out to Aerosmith
and ask if they would participate and
was like that sounds crazy to me but if
they'll do it obviously I'd love it you
know I love that band growing up they
were one of my favorite bands growing up
so that seemed like a dream
and then they came and we did it wow
that that was a groundbreaking moment in
music it really was
if you really stop and think about all
the ripples that came out of that that
particular song that that song
introduced so many people to hip-hop and
I'm sure so many hip-hop fans to rock
and roll and Run DMC absolutely you know
combining with Aerosmith is like the
perfect combination two iconic bands
but also at that point in time Aerosmith
had fallen on hard times I remember I
saw Aerosmith play at
Nassau Coliseum sold out incredible show
and then six months later
Aerosmith were playing at a club on Long
Island called speaks which was like a it
was like where the cover bands would
play six months six months what happened
I don't know I don't really know I think
maybe Joe Perry left the band which was
part of it
but I don't know how you can go from
that popular to to
in this new condition that quickly but
it happened
that's wild yeah I can't I wasn't aware
that that had happened that didn't that
doesn't even make sense that something
like that can happen in six months
Nassau Coliseum yeah which is like sold
out forty thousand twenty thousand
thousand something Jesus Christ to a
club yeah maybe 600 person club like a
big Club but still a club a big fall a
big fall wow yeah in six months yeah
really quick so was it a scandal when
Joe Perry left was that what it was was
it like everyone was upset I don't know
I really don't know
so they did that and then did that song
bring them back that song brought them
back wow yeah holy they had actually put
out an album called done with mirrors
which was like their comeback album
before Walk This Way
and that did not was not well received
and then Walk This Way came out and then
it both broke Run DMC in a mainstream
way and re-broke Aerosmith as mainstream
mainstream group